did you know that Will Smith shows up in
Gintama this isn't a question meant to
pique your interest in this anime based
on Hideyuki sriracha's manga far from me
actually because even if you're not a
fan of the series you probably know by
now that nothing about Gintama no matter
how outrageous should faze you and you
probably also know that one of his
specialties is parodies nobody does a
parody the way Gintama does no person
place event film TV show anime cultural
icon even can escape its insatiable
appetite for satire caricature and
mockery not even one of Hollywood's
biggest stars and while they say
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery I'm pretty sure game time is
doing it just for the loves nothing
wrong with that though by now you
probably know what today's video is all
about so without further ado let's get
on with it here are the top 10 parodies
in Gintama
now our first candidate is hardly a
surprise
it's Dragonball Z and it makes an
appearance in an episode with Hijikata
as the main character the story revolves
around the chain-smoking Shinsengumi
vice-captain making a trip to space to
smoke a cigarette in peace after all of
Edo enforces a strict ban on smoking the
plot however seems to be merely an
excuse for a truckload of DBZ references
hijikata's first stop is Planet hummock
which sounds suspiciously like nah MEK
what follows is a revolving door of
characters who bear a striking likeness
to some of DV Z's most celebrated
figures including Goku Frieza Cell and
krillen
at one point cigarettes take a back seat
as Hijikata goes in search of the Zulu
Zulu balls which point to the
wish-granting Dragon Balls of the
original series now the innuendos get
even more detailed with shoutouts to the
scouter device worn by friezes army and
the magical dragon Shenron some lines of
dialogue from DBZ become parody for de 2
what makes this episode even more
hilarious is that all these borrowed
characters are voiced by King Thomas
regulars who seem to be having a bit of
fun at poor hijikata's expense next we
have a Kuroko no basket spoof that's
sure to have you rolling around on the
floor laughing horror meets kick-the-can
meets assassination plot in this
flashback episode about Gintoki God Sura
Sakamoto and Takasugi shared past
invited to a reunion party by an
anonymous person kintoki
God surah and Sakamoto find themselves
haunted by an entire squad of unfriendly
ghosts in jerseys and shorts the parody
includes Kuroko's trademark move the
misdirection a technique that allows him
to become invisible and divert his
opponent's attention thanks largely to
his weak presence on the court in
Gintama this technique is used to play
kick-the-can
incidentally karoku and guru kono share
the same japanese voice actor if all
that basketball tomfoolery doesn't have
you in splits a scared witless kintoki
murdering the doraemon theme song is
sure to do the trick talk about a parody
within a parody
take ichigo's training in zangetsu's in
a world is anime legend and hence ripe
for the picking the parody begins with
kintoki Kagura and shinpachi waking up
in a pitch-black world where they meet
zangetsu clone toyoko you can't miss his
sunglass and cape resemblance to
zangetsu borracho offers cajoles
threatens and even begs to teach the
disinterested trio his ultimate
technique which only earns him a painful
kick in the thighs this sequence is
peppered with bleach references
unlike the authoritative zangetsu
booyaka is a pitiful figure a shut-in
with a kinky reading habit no friends
and an overbearing mama the spoof ends
with the odd-jobs gang beating him and
his dad up and mastering the ultimate
move the thigh burst in the process
bleach might have fallen off the radar
of fans but not of Gynt armors producers
it seems it makes another appearance
later on this time with dean Toki having
mastered ichigo's final getsuga tensho
form
the next target is Saint Seiya the hit
shown in series from the 1980s the spoof
comes smack in the middle of what
appears to be a regular Gintama episode
this one centered around scary stories
and ways to route kids out of their
money
Kagura comes up with a couple of stories
that all turn out to be parodies of
Saint Seiya one features a pair of
brothers who turn out to be the siblings
Phoenix Ikki and Andromeda shun the
bronze Saint Phoenix has the honor of
being overly exploited in this episode
which makes that scene of Gynt okie
getting worked up over potential
copyright trouble and another one where
he actually gets a call from the
copyright agency a nice touch but it's
the final moments when the parody
becomes pure gold as the credits roll
Keane Thomas cast gets an old-school
Saint Seiya makeover kintoki trades his
dead fish eyes for say our sparkly brown
peepers while all three odd job as
channel their inner Phoenix with their
gravity-defying blue bangs there is
really no end to the creative ways in
which Gintama Lampoon's other shows this
ending perfectly encapsulates that
creativity
[Applause]
next we have a parody of legendary
boxing series in the ring we have
shinpachi in one corner and [ __ ] kata or
rather his alter-ego Tashi in the other
the die hard or tacos are in the Battle
of a lifetime fighting for the right to
become the leader of the official or
suchan fan club high stakes indeed there
as you can see as the rivals throw
everything they've got to each other the
four similarities to our sheath are no
Joe and Hajime no Ippo are hard to miss
from the players fighting stance and
muscle flexing to the flying punches
steely glances and bloody noses
Gintama goes all-out to emulate the two
beloved boxing series the black eye
patch is worn by ginto key and Kagura
are an obvious shout-out to Joe's mentor
Dan pay from the 1970s series the
floating smoke on the other hand mimics
the animation of a pose fight sequences
if it weren't for the silliness of the
premise one might even call this episode
a tribute rather than a caricature
hopefully it inspired some views to
check out the original targets which are
definitely definitely worth a watch
all coming the next anime to get the
Gintama treatment is JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure this isn't just one episode
we're talking about but an entire arc
that's a good four episodes long Ginn
Toki and the gang find themselves at a
mountain ryokan or in for a hot spring
break unfortunately for the cowardly
kintoki the inn is haunted not by ghosts
but by stands and he's being roped in by
the innkeeper euler to serve these
special guests over incidentally has a
stand you might have guessed by now that
the ghostly stands here are no different
than the stands that serve as physical
manifestations of power in jojo's
universe a very obvious reference is a
clone of Jotaro Kujo stand star platinum
boy was rush attack is also typical of
JoJo's action sequences
the ghosts ryokan ark is one of the
funniest in the series with elements
from Japanese history and parodies of
other shows as well
but the Jojo digs are the ones that
really stand out your hut Callisto on to
number four now and it's a double parody
once again this time of rurouni kenshin
and Fist of the North Star Sol switches
are one of the most common tropes in
anime ink in Tamas no different in
episode 287 kintoki and Hijikata survive
a road accident but have their soul
switched the result is mayhem with an
authoritarian taking charge of the gyro
Zulia and a slacker in command of the
Shinsengumi in the chaos that ensues
shinpachi appears in a blue Hari and
slicked back hair his look and peculiar
sword stance or a play on Hajime site
though a character in rurouni kenshin
who happens to be the captain of the
Shinsengumi the blue Howry too is
inspired by the shinsengumi's uniform in
the old series meanwhile the
shinsengumi's Nurik in the parody
borrows heavily from Fist of the North
Star from their biker gang concept to
their purple Mohawks incidentally this
isn't the martial arts animes first
brush with Gynt armors parody machine go
back 100 episodes and you'll see a
shot-for-shot remake of Fist of the
North Stars opening
an early episode with a storyline about
new ideas to keep the Gintama anime from
being cancelled which is a constant
worry throughout the series leads to an
avalanche of parodies nothing is
sacrosanct anymore it seems but it's a
thighs idea that merged three shown in
classics that's probably the most
familiar the most memorable and hence
the funniest of the lot in the new
Gintama film of her imagination which
she cleverly titled dragon Polly piece
the arrow gang parody various characters
from Dragon Ball bleach in one piece so
you'll see Shinsengumi chief quando as
one piece villain crocodile Kondo again
as a Soul Reaper of bleach and Kondo a
third time as Dragon Ball antagonists
elf and each time he gets the stuffing
beaten out of him by oath I mean sama
has made a career of taking the piss out
of these three series that's for sure
bring out your lightsabres because it's
time for number two unlike the earlier
entries on this list
Gintama x' parody of pop culture giant
star wars comes couch within a serious
story on sirius by kintama standards of
course an old friend makes a comeback in
shinpachi and earth eyes lives Obi
Hajime named after the Jedi Master
himself and sharing his fondness for
Dolph Brown cloaks returns from a
distant planet as a master of the beam
sword style now the siblings pick him to
succeed their father as the head of
their family dojo naturally it's the
queue for plenty of jousting and
swordplay using lightsabers by the way
this isn't the first Star Wars parody
incan Tom actually 30 odd episodes
before Obi hajime's introduction the
odd-jobs gang fights off an army of
alien invaders led by the evil dark
Vader who's a parody of both Darth Vader
from Star Wars and char aznable from the
Gundam franchise apart from being an
Elizabeth look-alike that art even
recreates the familiar opening crawl of
the Star Wars movie may the fast be with
you forever Gintama
family knocking and now it's finally
time to unveil our top pick it comes in
the opening moments of the first episode
of season six which aired way back in
2017 rather than the standard recap of
the story so far the introduction has
enough parodies to last you a lifetime
and features all the big guns of the
shown in genre sample this okay Dean
Toki EADS the wave-wave fruit to get a
permanent perm and sets off on a voyage
to find the pirate Kings treasure one
piece check he meets a young girl in
search of magical balls that will summon
a dragon and together they defeat a
green-skinned villain Dragon Ball check
with their companion a pair of glasses
they enter the world tune in hunter hero
exam Naruto check hunter hunter
check in typical irreverent style
Gintama makes a mash of the series it
parodies in between there are some not
so obvious shoutouts to other anime
including kimono friends and probably
Pokemon is no one that the introduction
ends with shinpachi in a panic about
ripping off one too many shows well
that's what we love about Gintama isn't
it that it never shied away from doing
the outrageous and the obnoxious if you
haven't checked out the anime already I
strongly recommend you do before that
you can also check out my video why you
should watch Gintama on my second
channel vinnie tube kite on that note
that's a wrap from me Gintama is parody
gold as you know and sadly there are way
too many that I've had to leave out
today would you like me to make a volume
two or maybe more Gintama videos in
general like the good old days now if
this video gets 10,000 likes I'll
definitely consider it so leave a like
and let me know also drop me a comment
and tell me what your favorite parodies
in Gintama are i'd love to hear from you
also hit the like button if you would
and subscribe to vinnie tube for more
anime content stay safe and see you soon
[Music]
you